there are places in the universe where
gravity dramatically distorts space-time
[Music]
professor Stephen Hawking is renowned as
a world expert on black holes back in
the 1970s his groundbreaking research
brought much attention to the then
theoretical black hole the gravitational
pull of a black hole stretches and warps
space-time around it to an incredibly
deep cone-shaped hole when scientists
analyzed x-ray images of supermassive
black holes they discovered that they
were spinning at close to the speed of
light
this causes the space-time fabric to be
dragged around scientists call this
frame dragging space-time becomes so
distorted that it forms an almost
complete circle confirmation that black
holes rotate was music to the ears of
anyone interested in time-travel the
time traveller was just about to strike
gold Richard Gott is a professor of
astrophysics here at Princeton
University he searched the universe to
find anything that could warp space-time
as much as a rotating black hole what he
found led him to make a bold and
ambitious hypothesis which is based on
something that is still theoretical it's
called a cosmic string cosmic strings
are thin threads of energy that are left
over after the Big Bang
despite being no wider than an atom
cosmic strings have colossal density a
string just one yard long would exert
more gravity than the earth immense
gravity warps space-time with his eye on
time-travel that means one thing for
richard gott i found out that because of
the warping that's estranged in
space-time that if two strings infinite
strings were passing each other at high
speed like this you could use them to
make a time machine the fast-moving
strings warp space-time as they pass so
that they bend it down into a wedge
shape normally a spaceship would have to
take the longer route across space-time
but the time traveller can now take the
shortcut by outrunning a light beam he
can travel back in time if this car were
a huge spaceship and God could find two
cosmic strings he could return before he
departs
the space-time around the two moving
cosmic strings is so twisted that God
can circle the strings and come back
before he sets off here's how cosmic
strings bend space-time and provide a
shortcut by journeying around the
strings God travels faster than light
does across normal space-time you can't
build a rocket that goes faster than the
speed of light but with curved
space-time you can take a shortcut and
beat the light beam and theoretically
make a time machine in principle the
path of time is no longer linear instead
it forms something like a circle Richard
God's time machine does however have a
weak link he discovered that at the very
moment he warps space-time enough to
form a circle the whole region would
fall inside a black hole
and that's not good because a black hole
well that's a hotel where you check in
but you don't check out so it looks like
the the time travel region would be
trapped inside a rotating black hole
time-travel theories may sound
far-fetched yet for the last century
pioneers have pushed the boundaries
turning science fiction into reality
they have blended imagination with
knowledge to prove once and for all that
time travel will happen we may have only
journeyed a fraction of a second into
the future but the time travel pioneers
continue undeterred driven by the
knowledge that every epic adventure
begins with a single step